i think the thing that is like always
like i've never asked you this i'm just
like how the hell did this happen
yeah yeah yeah because it seems like
japanese anime would want to get
japanese composers so like how did this
all come around and i guess they have
for the longest time right yeah yeah so
what's your like background with no sure
i mean
well it's i mean it's a very super
random like kind of series of events
that like i don't really understand how
it happened i'm happy it did but i have
no idea actually how it happened but i i
guess like the the chronological events
is that i actually started working uh
probably yeah the in the end of my teens
i started working with the final fantasy
composer
wow yeah which is awesome
how did
bar once and i just ended up composing
like with the
final fantasy
i thought he said conception i was like
so yeah i
had always like wanted to do like video
game music um i remember because i
i uh my first game console um was
gamecube and i played this game called
metroid prime which is still my favorite
game amazing game right right yeah it is
one of my favorites um and uh when i
played the game i was like i want to do
that
and so that's basically what happened i
was like oh i want to do that one yeah
right and so
uh i kind of just like started you know
pretending to write video game music and
um australia also had a bunch of like
video game concerts that happened
including the final fantasy concerts
yeah uh but uh
in a slightly different did you just
burp no
i thought i had this click thing i was
like
yeah
okay shut the [ __ ] up
did you interrupt my story
um
so yeah australia had all these um kind
of concerts going on i met a conductor
called annie roth who did um some
concerts called play and so i went over
from perth western australia from where
i'm from uh when i was in sydney to do
this um
to kind of view this um
this concert and he invited me to come
say hello to him and also one of the
composers there who's the hill composer
akira yamakos i met him right that was
really cool and he was like super kind
of he was very very generous with his
time for like some eager you know piece
of [ __ ] 15 year old yeah i really
appreciate that even to this day but um
uh because i met annie when i saw that
um was going to come to a concert in
seattle yeah
i was like hey so
we might come over like me and my dad
like might come over and come say hi
right yeah and um they were like oh well
thank you for coming such a long way
from perth which is like 46 hours in a
plane right i'd recommend that by the
way yeah uh but yeah we sent like 36
hours going to seattle um met any and
then he was like oh let's come to the
dress rehearsal and come say hi as well
to tohimatsu
uh well because we met at that previous
one in sydney
um yeah it was very very lucky yeah you
make it sound very easy like like you
met him initially and you just bumped
into him initially or you're like no no
so like we had been invited to come say
hi at this concert in sydney which then
led to this concert in seattle where my
son was where we met for the first time
right right
and um australia all the um school um
sort of all the school years are flipped
because it's summer right okay
so because it's australia yeah because
australia yeah every everything's like
yeah
you've got to flip it like yeah
yeah yeah yeah and so that's when we
have like the at the classic school like
two three months kind of breakfast right
right right
basically like all of december and
january is just off yeah yeah okay yeah
but uh but um that was obviously like
new year's and stuff and christmas in
japan so yeah for summer holiday we
would go to
winter in japan right
end up very graciously say hello yeah
you can come say hi and stuff and yeah
eventually that just led to a couple of
um yeah it's like small it's not the
final fantasy game i should be very
clear about it right right but um yeah i
was yeah but you made some pretty insane
connections from that i've yeah i mean
it's still pretty crazy to talk about
but yeah you make it sound so easy like
yeah
you just had them on speed dial
i just went to a concert and then just
went to another concert and then just
you know things happen and then uh
yeah here i am honestly at the end of
the day i'm just i'm just happy it
happened i mean i know i've been using
that word a little bit too yeah it's
like yeah i'm just super just
things have just yeah panned out not
right not so [ __ ]
right i'm trying to piece the whole
thing in my head together like yeah me
too
how it all comes together yeah so you
met him again at another concert yeah
how did that translate into then working
for them because surely that's a massive
leap well we had because of these
japanese trips that i would do over
australian summer japanese winter yeah
what happened is we were able to um just
kind of keep a connection and then
eventually like i kept on submitting
some cds and stuff like that right okay
so right which in this case it worked
out but you know it's like i you never
think about it that way you just hope
you're the best to just you know just be
involved in some ways yeah yeah yeah it
feels nice so you just like kept
submitting you're working like i'm not
like okay okay i mean more like couples
they actually you know listen to it yeah
yeah yeah no obligation to do i would
not hold it against them to not do it
but yeah so graciously kind of did and
yeah eventually um i'm happy to say that
i was able to be useful to them so
so you were like making music from like
as early as like how old like oh [ __ ] um
like like i i assume very very young
right like were you like classically
trained and stuff or yeah so i played
flute i came from fluke
so see see you're playing fluid which is
such a funny history
i can do the um i can do the anchorman
certainly oh really i can do it like
that
why didn't you bring your flute yeah
um i actually like picked it up a little
bit uh last year like during the
pandemic so i was like oh it's [ __ ]
bored now so yeah yeah yeah yeah try it
again and ended up using it a bit on the
the new shield here and stuff so i did
something right
right yeah
wow
hell yeah cheeky jazz flute
so so you started with flute from like
uh really yeah and then you kind of just
went from there yeah flip playing play
metroid prime wanted to write music like
played on i'm not sure if you know
finale yeah yeah yeah yeah
for a little while and like didn't
understand what like working with actual
like you know daws and stuff yeah which
are digital audio audio workstations
yeah logic pro and stuff like that yeah
um and logic pro is eventually what i
moved to and still use it today mm-hmm
uh
yeah
yeah it's it's very overwhelming when
you look at it yeah
i know nothing about audio i i i'm that
guy dude
i'm like the connor of this episode i'm
like yeah that's uh that's letters that
you were saying right now i know more
yes
yeah
well um i said but connor was kind of
right with the whole beefs and boosting
a little bit oh we're getting into that
already
what
i know i hate to say but i like the
noise is the most accurate way to
describe how i feel about music as well
you're a you're a literal musician
you do this for a living oh my god my
life has been alive dude like i remember
i remember when connor first brought up
the whole like beeps and boop [ __ ] i was
like don't worry eventually when we get
kevin he'll be on my side
well i won't lie i like opened a bottle
of gin and just started drinking after
that
what the [ __ ] are you guys talking about
at the same time i was like to be honest
like yeah maybe we'll go into like a
little bit more detail about why the
noise is nice but they're not yeah the
noise is nice yeah i mean that's yeah
the things my ear is feeling you know i
like hearing them
yeah it's just soothing but we should
explore why we should explore why
what why why why why why though
that's that's like that's the level that
he's never crossed before
yeah i don't know is it i feel like it's
the most primitive way of experiencing
music like the way that it was just
meant like
is there any other
experience music because
everyone said this kind of like deep art
meaning and i'm like noise is nice you
know like it's just kind of like i don't
listen to a piece of music and they feel
any emotion yeah i just take it in and
i'm like
no i mean we all do but we also it's
that plus alpha for us you know like you
know it's not just the alpha all right
like yeah maybe describe it's like okay
so the noise is nice but it's the noise
is nice because like certain things that
are working together right right right
like said nice noise yeah yeah this is
what i brought you on today to explain
this concept
stupid way like i would expect yeah yeah
well i mean because like it's it's just
made up of like random kind of what's
the word i guess sort of category so
it's like you've got melody you've got
harmony you've got rhythm and stuff like
that texture text is really really
important so texture is like what what
is texture texture is
the sound quality the sound quality the
quality of a sound that's that's like
that's like you're saying you sounded
like an alien right now i was like
what does this texture you humans speak
of
i i don't normally talk to musicians and
normally when i hear someone talk about
texture it's with like food or like with
things that you feel like your hands
like the same thing yeah the exact same
concept it's like okay uh [ __ ] okay
okay you know the um
i think it's billie jean you know that
yeah
yeah okay the drums yeah the drum sound
is super distinctive yeah because it's
tech because anyone can play that beat
and anyone can play that like a drum
like that right why does it sound why do
you know that it's that [ __ ] song
straight away because the sound of the
drum the textual quality
specific and unique so that's the whole
idea of texture like texture i think
it's criminally not criminally and i
can't pronounce that [ __ ] word right
now but
primitively yeah primitively underrated
um no texture is like like i guess i
would call it like kind of the secret
ingredient
even though it's not a secret and you
know it's it's the spice that you add to
make it all come together right right
that's right there's many spices yeah
i i see like we've inadvertently like
separated the musicians on one side
like the the apes on the other side it's
got like a glass panel
don't [ __ ] come near it
yeah it's okay i feel like we talk about
anime yeah yeah i get it i get it okay
so you started you know doing you know
writing music from a young age you met
nobody so like how did you then go from
like that to
oh now i'm writing music for maine to
beers
because i feel again that's like not
like one-step process yeah uh there were
there were a couple of steps so so okay
number one how did you learn japanese
because i i assume you would need to
learn japanese to work in the year yeah
yeah yeah yeah i mean obviously i'm not
yeah i'm not i'm not this beautiful boy
when it comes to that but you know i i
feel like i do fine
yeah yeah yeah yeah i feel like i do
well and um so
yeah i learned japanese in australia
there's this thing called tafe which is
sort of a um a community college yeah
it's like
like sort of a yeah
not not universal you almost you can
treat it as like a pre-college almost at
some point yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you
do like certificate level stuff so
bachelorette certificate right sort of
underneath that yeah so uh i did that um
because i went to school at the west
australian academy of performing arts as
it's called
three years doing composition there yeah
um i was in perth but then um at night
time i was remember i remember i'm
trying to imagine me doing this now like
going to school during the day and yeah
go to school
and not have that energy that's right
anymore
by the way
[Applause]
welcome welcome to the club kevin
welcome to the club i am a little
because i can't even use the jet lag
excuse anymore
oh well no so i went to this tafe school
on my
thursday and a uh
wow let's try that again tuesday and
thursday yeah tuesday and thursday and
on the middle day the wednesday i would
go with all the classmates that i um
that like i was learning with and we're
gonna go to this seedy [ __ ] bar in
northbridge which is like kind of like
the uh i don't even know how to describe
it it's the uh
cd part of paper it is it is the like
club crazy like cd you know
[Music]
right
yes
[Laughter]
i've heard a lot of things about perfect
every australian i've met and one one
yeah one pattern that i've seen from
every australian i met from perth is
that they do not know they no longer
live in perth yeah i know i know four
people including you who are born and
raised in perth who are no longer in
perth yeah
so like i i do i would say that if
you've grown up there there is like a
certain like
shout out to our phantom
look there is a certain like jovial sort
of jokey aspect to like saying oh yeah
i'm from perth [ __ ] what yeah yeah
but like once you leave i think there is
like a little bit of homestick it's like
oh of course of course yeah
i [ __ ] miss it so much right right i
might be there for two two and a half
weeks and be like yeah i'm cool yeah
yeah how do you feel bye felicia but
yeah until then
i'm pretty homesick
but um but like yeah it so we went to
this bar
in northbridge because perth is super
super popular with working holiday
japanese people oh really super popular
i did not know that japanese people love
coming to perth and that's great and it
is it is what it's worth even though i
just like kind of described like some of
the first obviously [ __ ]
i'm trying to wrap my head around what
the reason that might
joey like i've never seen that facial
expression in joe where he tried to
understand either his japanese side or
his australian side and he's just like
there is something that's gone wrong
both my australian japanese side were
like that sounds like a lie
[Laughter]
as far as i can remember it's not but
right
i wonder why though ah
honestly sun
sun and beaches right yes
lots of whites yeah yeah they don't come
to the uk huh uh i already hear about
people in london
no
not really of course like it's also very
far away but i guess so is australia now
that i think yeah earth's pretty [ __ ]
far away yeah i mean like nothing yeah
yeah yeah that's true that's true the
connection between there is a connection
between australia and japan
and there's quite a lot of sister cities
and stuff right and obviously it's like
sort of the australasia region so yeah
that's triggering for y'all yeah but um
no the australasia region is um
obviously yeah i think there's there's a
lot of i mean pre-code of course there
was a lot of like kind of travel
treaties and stuff like that yeah yeah
yeah working holiday visas were
rampant yeah like a better word yeah um
but we would go to this bar and all the
working holiday people because it was a
shitty bar but on a wednesday night it
would be international night he wrote
ten dollar jugs and which is like i
think like
seven pound like 8.5 american dollars
right and uh yeah you just get [ __ ]
wasted with uh awesome like working
holiday japanese people and because
obviously when you're a bit toasted
you're right your language confidence
yeah right of course of course somehow
it just raises up yeah yeah okay that's
[ __ ]
yeah okay let's go yeah yeah yeah and um
so you would almost have like the two
formal training days on each side and
then you'd have like the
the real training day the toaster yeah
yeah yeah and your brain was just like
sponge it up
that was that's how it started and then
actually like since
since coveted we've been doing a lot
more like kind of business meetings and
stuff on zoom and stuff and so like my
keigo has like gone way through the roof
now because
it's like how i almost exclusively speak
like sort of with that like almost like
i always treat it as like a buffer it
almost feels like a buffer if like if
you're not right if you're not like not
sure how to speak to someone using the
keg almost feels like i'm just like
like
being safe yeah yeah safety right right
yeah you don't know where your like
relationship is yeah yeah yeah yeah
polite yeah exactly it's like i'm just
gonna avoid any like you know
by being overly polite right i did
notice that actually because like uh a
couple was it a couple months ago that
we did the main abyss event yeah like
because so i i did like co-host like a
maiden abyss event for me and abyss too
and obviously kevin wasn't there like in
person but he was on like a zoom call
because that was like a segment where we
were talking about the music for the
show and you know obviously because it's
a japanese event
live stream to a japanese audience yeah
kevin had to speak japanese for the
entire part yeah and uh you know i
hadn't heard kevin speak japanese in a
while so i was like oh you know
hopefully you know he'll
he'll get through it yeah and i was like
damn he's kegeling the [ __ ] god i was
like he's like way too polite
in this entire thing he's like he's like
talking to the [ __ ] prime minister
levels i'm like
i'm like he's just talking about like
the music he's like
the problem is because
i i've almost like lost the middle
ground now so it's like right way too
casual oh it's way too formal right
right and i was like just think because
it's like something tell me something
instead of saying like yes or something
i'm just like desk yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's just like you in a
nutshell right